investigating historical child sex abuse  is very difficult we've had quite a  moral uh crisis over the last 18 months  where initially it was said that very  senior members of government had lost  dossiers that they themselves were  subject to allegations and now here we  are the very obverse of that criticism  that in fact we weren't ignoring things  we've gone too far well surely it's  right that someone should look at that  and try and produce some balance and  perhaps it gives some guidance about how  police officers and others approach  these difficult historic allegations  where the evidence sometimes is lost  where people's memories have faded it's  so easy to make allegations but then how  do we prove them surely i think we all  need someone to look at that seriously